hi guys I have decided to do a contest
because many people like doing these and
I've never tried my hands at their
before so I figured I could try it now
this contest is going to be a bit
different from all the other clearly
inferior contests out there the
objective is to build the worst possible
rollercoaster not the best the worst now
you will be judged by Jim Appel on
hundreds of different criteria but I
decide with a complicated point system
and all that good stuff
Oh also there are rules rule number one
at ogre coaster is not eligible because
Togo's are by definition awesome - peeps
must be able to write the ride because
otherwise a roller coaster sucks and
you're stupid if you make a coaster
that's good but not functional 3 Racing
coasters are not allowed I don't know
why but I just felt like adding another
constricting rule for intamin is awesome
I just wanted to say that 5
loop-de-loops are allowed or rather
recommended doses that go upside down or
a cool 6 fast coasters are good coasters
just another recommendation kiddie
coasters suck and sceneries for [ __ ]
7 only trekked rides are allowed that's
pretty obvious anyway but whatever 8
overdone coasters are not allowed
because I suck at them myself and
therefore I will judge them negatively
knowing lava is not a viable piece of
scenery if you're adding lava to your
roller coasters you must be either
delusional or a mass murderer 10 stand
up coasters are banned for no other
reason than to make the contest more
challenging and because I hate them
so that's it it's time for you guys to
start building I wish you all great
success and I'll see on the
unnecessarily long results video bye